for more on the political news of the
week gone by and ahead CBS news
political correspondent ed O'Keefe joins
us now ed good morning let's start with
Joe Biden finally he is officially in
the race raised more than six million
dollars in that first 24 hour period how
has that changed the way things are
looking as far as the Democrats who are
running for president well so far he's
meeting expectations Dana he has
maintained his poll lead and he was able
to demonstrate pretty quickly that he
has the financial support needed to
build a campaign from scratch because
that's what he's doing I'm like most of
the other candidates in the race
Biden hasn't had a campaign operation of
his own in about 12 years so he's had to
go out and meticulously find people who
are gonna work for him and hope that the
money would come in quickly and it did
and it will continue to in the coming
days he has scheduled some big
fundraisers out in the West Coast and
early May and is also of course seeking
out the small dollar donations that are
driving a lot of the other campaigns
especially those of Bernie Sanders pepto
Rourke and Kamala Harris and we've seen
with the president with his I'm a young
vibrant man line already raising the age
question how significant do you think
that is going to be for for Biden well
you know Anthony I keep thinking since
that happened yesterday does America
really want a grumpy old men campaign or
are we gonna be looking for something
else you know I love that movie I was
partial Jack Lemmon do Americans really
want that
and-and-and-and first of all do
Democrats really want that do that is is
Biden setting himself up and
demonstrating the Democrats look issue
number one mission number one for us get
back the White House this is how we have
to do it we have to remind people this
guy is president we can't afford four
more years of him other Democrats are
gonna argue no let's just focus on the
issues let's try to look ahead let's try
to move on from what's been going on and
we'll see now over the next year or so
whether or not or with it which of those
arguments altum Utley prevails well we
definitely know the gloves of art come
off is this any indication of how the
president sizes up his opponent sure
look we know that he is concerned about
Biden because Republicans know Biden is
uniquely qualified to appeal in this to
voters in the states that Republicans
won
narrowly on election night in 2016
specifically Pennsylvania where Biden
will hold his first campaign rally on
Monday and where he's basing his
campaign headquarters Michigan Wisconsin
potentially Ohio places like Iowa all
across that mid industrial and
agricultural Midwest items argument is
we need to win those places back I can
do that I can make overtures to the
ascendant class and ascendant voters
that make up the Democratic Party
especially black voters in the south
young voters Latino voters will see but
it is a you know it is just looking at
what the president did there
you just wonder to yourself is the
country ready to stomach 15 more months
of that well II D up this week we know
that Attorney General Bill bar will be
in front of Congress what can we expect
to hear from him on May 1st you can
expect more fireworks when he testifies
before the House Judiciary Committee
than when he testifies before the Senate
Judiciary Committee it's because the
House Judiciary Committee's controlled
by Democrats of course the Senate
Judiciary Committee controlled by
Lindsey Graham and Republicans and they
are more likely to treat the Attorney
General with kid gloves compared to
Democrats so Thursday is the is the day
to watch when he goes to see members of
the House edie O'Keefe thanks very much
ed thank you